Vous vouliez me voir ?
Bonjour, partenaire.
Il faut qu’on parle.
Vous et moi nous avions un contrat.
Nous devions nous unir dans un seul et unique but :
baiser, c’est exact ?
Oui, oui, jusque-là c’est exact.
Vous deviez être mon partenaire pour qu’on se bouyave, parfois,
de temps en temps, quand l’envie nous en prenait.
Jusque-là on est d’accord ?
Oui, bien sûr.
On avait mis sur pied le plan cul.
Enfin, je vois pas vraiment où vous voulez en venir ?
J’en ai parlé avec mes associées,
on pense que vous essayez de me doubler.
C’est-à-dire ?
En tout vous avez liké 32 de ses photos sur Instagram,
favorisé 18 de ses tweets
et commenté environ 21 statuts Facebook.
Oui, effectivement, comme ça, ça fait des chiffres un peu impressionnants mais …
Le lundi 19, vous lui avez proposé un petit ciné,
et pas n’importe lequel : un film de Woody Allen.
Alors ça, c’est un hasard total,
à la base je voulais proposer le dernier Fast and Furious.
Vendredi 23 nous avons intercepté un texto disant, je cite :
« Juste un petit message pour te dire que je pensais à toi :)»
Oui …
-Le mardi 27, vous lui avez envoyé :
« Salut toi, pas de nouvelles :(
J’espère que tu vas bien <3 »
Ok, donc je peux pas parler en fait …
Et le dimanche 8,
vous m’avez demandé si je voyais d’autres hommes.
Ouais …
Oui mais ça c’était pour …
pour faire la conversation,
vu que vous répondiez pas …
C’est pas comme si …
Vous m’aviez présenté vos parents ?
-Voilà.
Ça aussi vous l’avez fait.
Oui, oui c’est vrai.
Vous vous êtes attaché.
Avouez-le.
Oh, oh, ok c’est vrai.
J’espérais autre chose que le plan cul, oui.
Comment t’as pu pensé un truc pareil ?
Depuis l’interception Tinder, on s’était mis d’accord.
Juste du kiff, rien de sérieux.
Ben c’est pas ma faute, ok ?
Et puis voilà, ce qu’on peut faire,
idée, idée, pouf, pouf ! On oublie !
Et demain, oh je sais pas, imaginons tu m’appelles :
« - Dring, dring.
- Allo ?
Ouais, salut, c’est Aïlis !
- Oh, bonjour Aïlis, mais quel bon vent t’amène ?
Ben je sais pas, j’avais envie de discuter,
peut-être que demain on pourrait se voir et on pourrait se pécho grave.
Mais complètement Aïlis, c’est une super idée,
mais rappelle-toi ce qu’on …
Baptiste, Baptiste, Baptiste …
C’est trop tard,
j’en sais trop.
Ah putain ça fait super mal !
Ça va ?
C’est bon, calme toi, t’inquiètes, ça va aller.
C’est rien.
T’inquiètes mec, elle en vaut pas la peine de toute façon.
Et puis t’en trouveras d’autres !
Putain mais ça m’aide pas du tout ce que tu dis là !
Et au pire y’a la sœur de Thomas.
Quoi ?
Y’a ta sœur.
- « Au pire » y’a ma sœur ?
Donc déjà, au pire, non.
Du coup, dès que j’ai eu mon diplôme,
j’ai commencé à travailler dans un cabinet de médecin dans le 15ème.
T’es sûr que ça va ?
Oui, oui, tout va bien.